Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. Three massive piles rose prominent before our view from an extensive and confused series of mounds, at once showing the importance of the ruins which we, their first European visitors, now rapidly approached. The whole was surrounded by a lofty and strong line of earthen ramparts, concealing from view all but the principal objects. Beyond the walls were several conical mounds, one of which equalled in altitude the highest structure within the circumscribed area. Each step that we took after crossing the walls convinced me that Waka was a much more
感谢您收听《历史的剩余》。若想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、提前解锁系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。在开阔而凌乱的土丘前方，三座巨大的高丘赫然映入我们的眼帘，这顿时显现出这些遗迹的重要性。作为这片废墟的首批欧洲访客，我们正迅速向其靠近。整个遗址周围环绕着一道高大坚固的土质防御工事，将除主体建筑之外的所有景观都遮挡在视线之外。城墙之外有数座圆锥形土丘，其中一座的高度甚至与限定区域内的最高建筑不相上下。越过城墙后，我们迈出的每一步都让我确信，瓦卡（Waka）是一个比以往
important place than had been hitherto supposed, and that its vast mounds, abounding in objects of the highest interest, deserved a thorough exploration. I determined, therefore, on using every effort to make researches at Waka, which of all the ruins in Chaldea, is alone worthy to rank with those of Babylon and Nineveh. So Tom, that was Sir William Loftus, and he's writing in Travels and Researches in Chaldea or Chaldea and the Susiana, which is in 1857. He's a British geologist, isn't he? And he's been working as part of an international commission, drawing up the border between the empires of the Ottomans
人们想象中更为重要的地点，其庞大的土丘中蕴含着极具价值的文物，值得进行彻底的勘探。因此，我下定决心，要尽一切努力在瓦卡开展研究。在迦勒底的所有废墟中，唯有这里才配得上与巴比伦和尼尼微相提并论。汤姆，这位就是威廉·洛夫特斯（Sir William Loftus）爵士，他的这段文字出自 1857 年出版的《迦勒底及苏西亚纳旅行与研究》（Travels and Researches in Chaldea or Chaldea and the Susiana）。他是一位英国地质学家，对吧？他曾作为国际委员会的成员参与绘制奥斯曼帝国
and the Persians. So tell us what he's the place he's talking about here, because this is one of we love a mystery story. And this is one of history's greatest mysteries. So it's a very mysterious place. As he said in his book, it's called Waka and it's in southern Mesopotamia. It had been a frontier post of the Persian Empire back in the age of Muhammad. But when the Arabs had conquered the Persian Empire, it had effectively been abandoned. And it's a site like Ozymandias, nothing beside remains. You know, you have the lone and level sands stretching far away. And Loftus actually says that it's the most desolate spot that he had ever visited. But
与波斯帝国之间的边界。那么，请跟我们讲讲他在这里谈论的地方，因为这是——我们都热爱悬疑故事——而这正是人类历史上最大的谜团之一。所以这是一个非常神秘的地方正如他在书中提到的那样，这个地方叫瓦卡，位于美索不达米亚南部。早在穆罕默德的时代，它曾是波斯帝国的边境哨所。但当阿拉伯人征服波斯帝国后，这里实际上就已经被废弃了。这是一个如同奥兹曼迪亚斯（Ozymandias）一般的遗址，周遭什么也没有留下。你知道的，唯有孤寂平坦的沙原向远方延伸。洛夫特斯甚至说，这是他去过的最荒凉的地方。不过
he does sense that there's something important about it, something strange about it. And there absolutely is. And people who are watching this on YouTube will realize that we're not recording this at home. And we are in fact in Manhattan, we're in New York City, I guess in lots of ways the archetype of a great modern international metropolis. And there is a link joining New York, London, Tokyo, Beijing, all the great cities of the world to this desolate spot. But it's not immediately obvious just how significant a place this is. And it takes a process of archaeology stretching right the way up to the present day. So Loftus himself, he does come back, he does some kind of desultory excavations and then
他确实隐约感觉到这里有着非同寻常的重要性，有着某种诡异之处。而事实也的确如此。在 YouTube 上观看这段节目的观众会发现，我们并非在家中录音。事实上，我们身处曼哈顿，在纽约市，我想在很多方面，这里都是一个伟大的现代国际大都市的原型。有一条纽带将纽约、伦敦、东京、北京以及世界上所有伟大的城市与这个荒凉的地方连接在一起。但这个地方究竟有多重要，并不是一眼就能看出来的。这需要一个绵延至今的考古过程。所以，洛夫特斯本人确实曾再次造访，进行了一些零星的挖掘，然后
he leaves Waka. And then Germans come in, they're excavating here just before the First World War, they continue after that. Obviously, there have been kind of interruptions for the various Iraq wars over recent years. But the process of archaeology has revealed that Loftus's initial sense that this was a really key spot was absolutely true. And as you say, it is a place so full of mystery that you might say that this is one of the great mysteries in the entire story of human history. Well, Tom, is it not fair to say that this story that we're going to be telling today is arguably one of the most consequential significant stories we've ever told on the
他就离开了瓦卡。接着，德国人来到这里，在第一次世界大战爆发前不久在此进行发掘，并在战后继续这项工作。当然，近年来由于历次伊拉克战争，挖掘工作曾有过各种中断。但考古进程已经表明，洛夫特斯最初的直觉——即这里是一个至关重要的地点——是完全正确的。正如你所说，这是一个充满了谜团的地方，你甚至可以说，这是整个人类历史长河中最伟大的谜团之一。那么，汤姆，我们今天要讲述的故事，可以说是我们在《历史的剩余》中讲过的最具影响力、最重要的故事之一，这样说难道不过分吗？因为这个神秘的废墟之城，可以说就是人类历史中最为重要的地方
rest of history? Because this mysterious ruined city, you could argue is the single most important place in the history of humankind Yeah, because it's the site for one of the if not the greatest turning points in the whole history of human civilization So what is it about waka that makes it so significant? There are two dimensions to it. The first is it is Incredibly old so I said that it gets abandoned in the age of Muhammad So around a few generations after the Arab conquest. So about 700.
没错，因为它是人类文明史上最伟大的转折点之一（如果不是最伟大的话）的所在地。那么，瓦卡究竟有什么特别之处，让它如此重要？这可以从两个维度来看。首先，它极其古老。我刚才提到，它在穆罕默德的时代被废弃，也就是在阿拉伯征服几代人之后，大约公元 700 年左右。
Yeah, about that. But we now know that the origins of this place stretch all the way back to 5000 BC. So it's been continuously inhabited for almost 6000 years. And we now know that it was a place originally called Uruk. But you can see that, you know, Waka Uruk, it's clearly the same place. Yeah. But the other thing about it, it's not just that it's old, but that it is by the standards of every other settlement, say around, um, 4,000 or 3000 BC.
是的，差不多那个时候。但我们现在知道，这个地方的起源可以一直追溯到公元前 5000 年。所以它已经连续有人居住近 6000 年了。我们现在知道，这里最初是一个叫做乌鲁克（Uruk）的地方。不过你能看出来，瓦卡和乌鲁克显然是同一个地方。是的。但关于它的另一件事是，它不仅历史悠久，而且以公元前 4000 年或公元前 3000 年左右其他所有定居点的标准来看，
It is enormous. Right. So imagine you are approaching this place Uruk in 3000 BC and what do you see as you approach it? You are surrounded by canals, by irrigation systems, by fields. The fields are full of crops. They're also full of livestock. As you draw nearer to it, you then see something that you would see nowhere else on the face of the planet at this time. And it is a thing of wonder and there are writers later from Uruk who will praise it in these terms.
它的规模极其庞大。没错。所以想象一下，你在公元前 3000 年走近乌鲁克这个地方，当你靠近时，你看到了什么？你的周围是运河、灌溉系统和田野。田野里庄稼长得满满当当，还养满了牲畜。当你走得更近时，你会看到当时地球上任何其他地方都绝对看不到的景象。那是一个奇迹，后来乌鲁克的一些作家正是用这样的辞藻来赞美它：
This fastness thrusting high above the Azea plain around, this city sprouting tall from Earth to see, this Uruk whose very name gleams like the rainbow. Everything about it is hyperbole. It is the wonder of the world. There are vast city walls. So these are the walls that Loftus sees. Yeah. They're about 23, 24 feet tall, six miles in circumference within the walls.
这座坚固的堡垒高耸于周围的阿齐亚（Azea）平原之上，这座城市从大地上拔地而起，直插云霄；这就是乌鲁克，它的名字犹如彩虹般闪耀。关于它的每一句话都是夸张之词。它是世界的奇迹。这里有宏伟的城墙。是的，这就是洛夫特斯看到的那些城墙。它们大约有 23 到 24 英尺高，周长达 6 英里，城墙内部……
As you approach it, you can see that there are two towering temples. The first of these is called the Ayyana, which literally means the house of heaven, and it is sacred to the goddess who, in the opinion of the people of Uruk, founded the city. And this is a goddess called Inanna, who the Babylonians subsequently would call Ishtar, great powerful civilization-bringing goddess. The other temple is a temple to the great sky god Anu and this is sheathed in gleaming white plaster. It's radiant, it catches the lights of the sun, so that's what the meaning of the phrase gleaming like the rainbow. Again, a stupefying sight if you've never seen anything like this.
当你走近时，你可以看到两座高耸的庙宇。其中第一座被称为埃安纳（Eyyana），字面意思是“天堂之家”，它是献给乌鲁克人民心目中这座城市的奠基女神的。这位女神就是伊ナン娜（Inanna），巴比伦人后来称她为伊什塔尔（Ishtar），这是一个伟大的、强大的、带来文明的女神。另一座庙宇则是献给伟大天空之神安努（Anu）的，它外表覆有闪闪发光的白色灰泥。它光芒四射，捕捉着阳光，这就是“像彩虹一样闪耀”这句话的含义。同样，如果你从未见过这样的景象，这绝对是一个令人目瞪口呆的奇迹。
You then go in through the gates, you're surrounded by market gardens, so you know, dates and various things like that. There are industrial zones, so brick making factories, potteries, all this kind of stuff. And then you go into the actual city itself and it is, again, I mean, this is a place that it has no comparison anywhere. It's cramped, it's labyrinthine, the houses have no windows so that it keeps the heat out so it remains cool even in the heat of summer. And these are carefully zoned districts, so a lot of thought has gone into the urban planning. The population may be as high as 80,000. I mean, 80,000 people concentrated in a single space. And the total area of the city within the city walls is about three square miles and just for a point of comparison the walls of imperial Rome in its
然后你穿过城门，周围是菜园，比如长着枣椰树和各种类似植物的地方。这里有工业区，比如砖窑、陶器厂，诸如此类。接着你进入了真正的城市内部，这是一个在任何地方都找不到可比之处的地方。这里拥挤不堪，错综复杂，房屋没有窗户，这样可以把热量挡在外面，即使在炎热的夏天也能保持凉爽。这些是经过精心规划的区域，城市规划投入了大量的心血。人口可能高达 8 万。我是说，8 万人集中在一个空间里。城墙内的总面积大约为三平方英里。为了做个对比，全盛时期的帝国罗马
heyday so around 8200 contained an area only twice that size. Right so we've got a huge place, temples, tens of thousands of people, we have the factories, we have the canals, we have all that kind of stuff and I guess it's the combination of the two things, isn't it? The fact that it's so vast and the fact that it's so old, that means that historians, archaeologists have seen this as the world's first city. It's the first place where human beings live together in what we would now call the ancestor of New York or Chicago or London or wherever. Yeah. This is where urbanism begins. This is where the story that culminates in the city we're in now, New York, this is where
也就是公元 8200 年左右，其城墙内的面积也只有这个数字的两倍。没错，所以我们有一个巨大的地方、庙宇、数万名居民、工厂、运河以及所有这些东西。我想正是这两者的结合，对吧？它如此庞大，又如此古老，这意味着历史学家和考古学家将其视为世界的首座城市。这是人类首次聚居在一起的地方，我们现在可以称之为纽约、芝加哥、伦敦或其他任何地方的先祖。是的。城市化就是从这里开始的。这个故事最终在我们将要身处其中的城市——纽约——达到顶峰，而这一切都是
it starts. And in the fourth millennium, to quote Gwendolyn Lyke, who wrote a book called Mesopotamia, tellingly the subtitle is The Invention of the City. I mean, she describes it as being the only really large urban center in the fourth millennium. And so the question then is, how did U Uruk begin and why was it Uruk? Why was it this particular place? And the arguments around it and the fascination of this kind of puzzle actually remind me of the arguments that people have about why industrialization began in Britain.
从这里开始的。正如格温多琳·莱克（Gwendolyn Lake）在她的著作《美索不达米亚》中所说的那样（颇具意味的是，该书的副标题是《城市的的发明》），在公元前四千年，她将其描述为公元前四千年唯一真正的大型城市中心。那么问题来了，乌鲁克是如何起源的？为什么偏偏是乌鲁克？为什么是这个特定的地方？围绕它的争论以及这种谜题的魅力，实际上让我想起了人们关于英国为什么会发生工业革命的争论。
There are lots of places that you might think of where industrialization could have happened and they don't. So why does it specifically happen in Britain? And likewise, why does urbanization happen in Uruk? And then there is a further question, a further mystery, which is how does this process of urbanization change humanity? Because if this is the first experience in history of people living together in a city, does it change what it is to be human?
有很多地方你可能会觉得工业革命本可以在那里发生，但它们没有。那么为什么它偏偏在英国发生了？同样，为什么城市化会发生在乌鲁克？此外还有一个更深层次的问题、一个更大的谜团，那就是城市化进程是如何改变人性的？因为如果这是历史上人类首次聚居在城市中，这是否改变了身为人的意义？
Does it kind of rewire the brain? Does it set up patterns of behavior and social intercourse that have no precedent when Uruk is built, but which we now take for granted? So it's just such an amazing story, I think. Well, let's try to put this in a bigger context, Tom. So the great sort of shift in human history, the first great shift or the agricultural revolution, that happens at the end of the last ice age, which is almost 12,000 years ago. And that's the point at which hunter gatherers start domesticating
它是否重塑了人类的大脑？它是否建立了一套在乌鲁克建造时前所未有、而我们现在却习以为常的行为模式和社交方式？所以我觉得这是一个非常了不起的故事。好吧，汤姆，让我们试着把这件事放在更大的背景下来看。人类历史上的重大转变——第一次重大转变，即农业革命——发生在上一冰河时代末期，也就是将近 1.2 万年前。那是猎人采集者开始驯化
crops. And obviously Mesopotamia, Iraq, as we would now call it, that kind of zone, because it's the fertile crescent, and it's the most obvious place for agriculture to start. So tell us something about that to give us a bit of context for this. Yeah, so Mesopotamia is part of the fertile crescent, but the fertile crescent consists of more than Mesopotamia. So you've also got the uplands of Anatolia, what's now Turkey, you've got Syria going down into Israel, Palestine. And the thing about the fertile crescent is that it has an incredible array of, you know, soil types, of variations of climate, of altitude. So that means that there are lots of different crops, lots of different plants growing.
农作物的时期。显而易见，美索不达米亚（我们现在所说的伊拉克）那个地带，由于属于“新月沃地”，是农业发源最显而易见的地方。所以给我们讲讲这方面的背景，好让我们对这件事有个大致的了解。好的，美索不达米亚是新月沃地的一部分，但新月沃地的范围不仅限于美索不达米亚。它还包括安纳托利亚的高地（即现在的土耳其）、叙利亚，一直延伸到以色列和巴勒斯坦。新月沃地的神奇之处在于，它拥有极其丰富的土壤类型、气候变化和海拔高度。这意味着这里生长着各种各样不同的农作物和植物。
And this is the home of lots of different varieties of wheat. You get barley, you get lentils, peas, you get flax, which of course is quite useful for making clothing. But also as well as plant life, you also have fauna. And you remember we talked about this in the context of the Aztecs as why the Americas do not develop in the way that Eurasia does. They don't have draft animals. And also they don't have animals that they can domesticate. So the ancestors of sheep, of goats, of cows, of pigs, all of which are part of human agriculture today, I mean this again, this is where it begins. And if you're
这里是多种小麦的发源地。你还可以找到大麦、小扁豆、豌豆、亚麻（当然，亚麻对制作衣物非常有用）。除了植物，这里还有动物。还记得我们在阿兹特克的背景下讨论过美洲为什么没有像欧亚大陆那样发展吗？因为它们没有役畜。而且它们也没有可以驯化的动物。因此，绵羊、山羊、牛、猪的祖先——所有这些今天人类农业不可或缺的动物——这一切，同样也是从这里开始的。如果你是一个
a hunter-gatherer, if you're kind of roaming around, and then you find a spot where, you know, there's wild wheat growing and also you have herds of animals, then why would you continue roaming? You might as well kind of settle down and enjoy the fruits of nature. And that is what people do start to do very, very early on. And these camps then start to become kind of settled communities. So probably the oldest, certainly the most famous of these kind of hunter gatherer camps that become a permanent settlement is Jericho in what's now on
采集狩猎者，到处游荡，然后你发现了一个地方，那里不仅长着野生小麦，还有成群的动物，那你为什么还要继续游荡呢？你不如就在这里定居下来，享受大自然的果实。这正是人们在非常非常早的时候开始做的事情。接着，这些营地开始演变成某种定居社区。因此，其中可能最古老、也最著名的由狩猎采集营地演变而来的永久定居点，就是位于现在
the West bank. People will say Jericho is the oldest inhabited place on the planet, don't they? So it's about 11,000 years old. It's the oldest continuously inhabited because it's a city to this day. It's not initially what we would call a city. It shows, you know, there are kind of developments that will become features of urbanism. So Jericho, people first settled
约旦河西岸的杰里科（Jericho）。人们常说杰里科是地球上有人居住的最古老的地方，对吧？它有大约 11000 年的历史。它是最古老的持续有人居住的地方，因为它至今仍然是一座城市。它最初并不是我们所说的城市。它展现出了一些将成为城市化特征的发展迹象。因此，杰里科的人们最早在那里定居
there about 11,000 years ago and by about 9,000 BC, you've got reliable winter rains, you've got productive harvests and abundant wild game. So these are the words of Stephen Mithin in his book, After the Ice. And he says the Jericho people had no need to leave. And they start to build walls and they even build a tower. And Mithin says that such architecture was completely unprecedented in human history. So there are kind of foreshadowings of urbanism there, but it doesn't become a city. There's no urban liftoff. It's just a large village.
大约在公元前 11000 年左右，到公元前 9000 年左右，那里已经有了可靠的冬雨、丰收的庄稼和丰富的野生猎物。这是斯蒂芬·米森（Stephen Mithen）在他的书《冰河时代之后》（After the Ice）中所用的词句。他说，杰里科的人们没有必要离开。他们开始建造城墙，甚至还建了一座塔。米森说，这种建筑在人类历史上是前所未有的。因此，其中已经有了城市化的先兆，但它并没有变成一座城市。这里并没有出现城市的腾飞。它只是一个大型村庄。
I mean, in due course, it will become a city, but not for many, many thousands of years in the future. And this is true of other settlements as well across the Fertile Crescent that are kind of starting to sprout up in a similar way to Jericho. There's a very famous one called Çatalhayık in Turkey, maybe about 5,000 inhabitants there. So this is in the seventh millennium. It seems to be quite an oppressive place. They love a skull. They do. I think you in the seventh millennium. It seems to be quite an oppressive place. They love a skull. They do. I think you get the sense that the people living there, I mean, they're menaced all the time by a sense of the supernatural around them. So not, I think a particularly pleasant place to live. Yeah. Like New York. That doesn't take off.
当然，在不久的将来它会成为一座城市，但那要在数千年之后了。新月沃地各处以类似杰里科的方式开始萌芽的其他定居点也是如此。土耳其有一个非常著名的定居点叫恰塔霍裕克（Çatalhöyük），那里大约有 5000 名居民。这是在公元前七千年。这里似乎是一个相当压抑的地方。他们很喜欢头骨。确实如此。我觉得你在公元前七千年的遗址中能感受到，那里的人们似乎一直受到周围超自然力量的威胁。所以，我觉得它并不是一个特别宜居的地方。就像纽约一样。那个地方并没有真正腾飞。
And there is also down in Mesopotamia, you're also starting to get these kinds of proto cities, large villages developing both in the north and the south of Mesopotamia. So an example of a city in the north is a place called Tel Brak in what's now Syria merges about the same time as Chattel Hayek. So the seventh millennium and by the fourth millennium, it seems to be ready for liftoff rather like you might say the Netherlands is ready to industrialize in the 17th century, but it doesn't. It remains basically a large village. And then by the end of the fourth
此外，在美索不达米亚南部，你也开始看到这类原初城市——大型村庄在美索不达米亚的北部和南部同时发展起来。北方的一个城市例子是位于现在叙利亚的一个叫特尔布拉克（Tel Brak）的地方，它大约与恰塔霍裕克同时期崛起，即公元前七千年。到了公元前四千年，它似乎已经准备好腾飞了，就像你可以说荷兰在 17 世纪准备好工业化一样，但它并没有。它基本上仍然是一个大型村庄。然后到了公元前四世纪末
millennium, it goes into remission. It's kind of contracting, it's disintegrating, it's collapsing. But this is the very time down in southern Mesopotamia, the Uruk is starting to enjoy takeoff. So to quote Guillermo Algarze, and I hope I've pronounced his name right, might be Algeis, but I'll call him Algarze, who's written a book, Ancient Mesopotamia at the Dawn of Civilization, and he puts it in this way, a decisive shift in favor of Southern Mesopotamia, of the balance of urbanization, sociopolitical complexity, and economic differentiation that had existed across the ancient East until the onset of the fourth millennium. So something is happening in southern Mesopotamia, the place where Uruk
年代，它开始衰退。它在收缩、解体、崩塌。但与此同时，美索不达米亚南部的乌鲁克却开始迎来腾飞。借用吉列尔莫·阿尔加泽（Guillermo Algaze）的话（我希望我没有念错他的名字，可能是阿尔盖斯，但我叫他阿尔加泽），他写过一本书《文明曙光时的古代美索不达米亚》（Ancient Mesopotamia at the Dawn of Civilization），他是这样表述的：城市化平衡、社会政治复杂性以及经济分化向美索不达米亚南部的决定性转变，打破了自公元前四千年开始之前一直贯穿古代东方的格局。因此，美索不达米亚南部——即乌鲁克
will emerge that is happening nowhere else hadn't happened in Syria, hadn't happened in Palestine, hadn't happened in Anatolia, hadn't happened in northern Mesopotamia. So why? So, I mean, this is obviously a fascinating, very, very pressing question. And so there have been lots of very broad brush theories about it. And the earliest theories were that Uruk, where it emerges, that it's the result of conquest by outsiders. And these outsiders have been called the Sumerians. And the analogy that is often pursued is with the emergence of where we are today, Manhattan, over the course of the 17th into the 18th century, because there had to be no sign of urbanization here, and then with the coming of European colonialists, you
将要崛起的地方——正在发生着其他任何地方都没有发生过的事情。这在叙利亚没有发生过，在巴勒斯坦没有发生过，在安纳托利亚没有发生过，在美索不达米亚北部也没有发生过。那么，为什么呢？所以，这显然是一个迷人且非常非常紧迫的问题。因此，人们提出了许多宏观的理论。最早的理论认为，乌鲁克的崛起是外来者征服的结果。这些外来者被称为苏美尔人。人们经常采用的类比是，我们今天所在的曼哈顿在 17 世纪到 18 世纪期间的发展过程，因为这里原本没有任何城市化的迹象，然后随着欧洲殖民者的到来，
start to get the city that we're now sitting in. So is this proof that the Sumerians had come and they had planted this great city in the middle of nowhere? But that's not really an answer, because it's just kicking the problem down the can down the road, because where did the Sumerians get the idea for urbanism from? It doesn't really answer the puzzle. And also recent archaeology, so over recent decades, has demonstrated beyond a shadow of doubt that there were no newcomers, that the people we call the Sumerians were very, very anciently rooted there. The parallels of the culture of Uruk
我们现在所在的这座城市便拔地而起了。那么，这是否证明苏美尔人曾经到来，并在荒郊野岭中建立起这座伟大的城市呢？但这并非真正的答案，因为这只是把问题向后推延了，苏美尔人的城市化理念又是从哪里来的呢？这并没有真正解答这个谜题。而且，近几十年来的考古学毫无疑问地证明了，根本没有外来者，我们称之为苏美尔人的人群早在远古时期就在那里扎根了。乌鲁克文化的相似性
are easily traceable to the archaeological remains that precede the emergence of Uruk. So that theory is no longer accepted. And then there's another theory, which I think is probably on the popular level, it's one that lots of people I think would probably assume is the explanation. And that is that although Mesopotamia is very fertile, it's also quite difficult to channel that fertility. You know, you've got these two great rivers, the Tigris and the Euphrates. And if you're going to irrigate the mudflats beyond them, you need great workforces to dig the irrigation canals. And the only way that this could have been organized would be by having a powerful elite who could organize
可以很容易地追溯到乌鲁克崛起之前的考古遗存中。所以这一理论不再被接受了。然后还有另一种理论，我认为在大众层面，这可能是许多人会认为的解释。那就是，尽管美索不达米亚非常肥沃，但要引导这种肥力也相当困难。你知道的，这里有两条大河，底格里斯河和幼发拉底河。如果你想灌溉河流两岸的泥滩，你需要庞大的劳动力来开凿灌溉运河。而唯一能够组织起这种工程的方式，就是拥有一个能够组织
the masses to do it for them. And this in turn, once it's been done, would generate surpluses and these surpluses could then start to be spent on massive walls and temples, towers and stuff. And of course also keeping the elites in the comfort to which they're becoming used. And so for the elites of Uruk, this would be brilliant. It would be a kind of virtuous circle because they get richer and richer and the oppressed masses get more and more enslaved to them, more and more obliged to labor to keep them in the style that they're accustomed to.
大众来完成这项工作的强大精英阶层。一旦这项工作完成，反过来又会产生剩余物资，而这些剩余物资随后就可以用来建造巨大的城墙、神庙、高塔之类的东西。当然，这也让精英阶层能够过上他们渐趋习惯的舒适生活。因此，对于乌鲁克的精英阶层来说，这绝对是绝妙的。这是一个良性循环，因为他们变得越来越富有，而受压迫的群众则越来越沦为他们的奴隶，越来越被迫劳作，以维持他们习惯的生活方式。
Now this theory also has fallen by the wayside and that's because today there is a recognition that what is happening in the fourth millennium BC, and it's only really recently been conclusively proved, is a process of climate change. And you have rising sea levels. And the Persian Gulf, back in the fifth millennium, going into the fourth millennium, it reaches inland about 200 miles higher than it does today. So much higher up into the kind of the flatlands of what is now Iraq. And the spread northwards of seawater means that you have an unbelievably rich
现在，这种理论也已经被淘汰了。这是因为今天人们认识到，公元前四千年正在发生的事情（而且直到最近才被确凿地证明），是一个气候变化的过程。当时海平面正在上升。在公元前五千年到公元前四千年的时期，波斯湾向内陆延伸的距离比主要高出大约 200 英里。也就是说，它更深入地侵入了现在伊拉克的平原地带。海水向北蔓延，意味着你拥有了难以置信的丰富
variety of potential foodstuffs. You have seafish, you have mollusks, you have marshlands and in them you have kind of waterfowl, you have the floodplain, of course, where you can grow wheat. And then you have kind of more arid, almost kind of semi-desert regions where you can keep livestock. So essentially, it's potentially a massive great larder. And so it's understandable that as the seawater spread northwards into what's now Iraq, so people start to congregate along its shores and to go out into the marshes and to kind of build settlements there. And the result of this, the fact that you have this whole
潜在食物来源。这里有海鱼、软体动物、沼泽地，沼泽里有水禽，当然还有可以种植小麦的冲积平原。此外，还有更干旱、几乎半沙漠化的地区，你可以在那里放牧牲畜。从本质上讲，这里潜在地成为了一个巨大的天然储藏室。因此，随着海水向北蔓延到现在的伊拉克境内，人们开始聚集在海岸线上，走进沼泽地，并在那里建立定居点，这是完全可以理解的。其结果是，由于你拥有了如此广阔的
range of ecosystems, is it seems in the fifth and then into the fourth millennium, you're starting to get a greater concentration of people than anywhere else on the planet. So I remember reading something about this in a book a few years ago by Ben Wilson called Metropolis. It's a brilliant book. Yeah. And he was talking about people building these sort of settlements on these marshy islands. And there's one in particular, isn't there, where they build a shrine.
生态系统范围，似乎在公元前五千年及之后的公元前四千年里，这里的人口集中度开始超过地球上的任何其他地方。我记得几年前在本·威尔逊（Ben Wilson）的一本书《大都会》（Metropolis）中读到过类似的内容。那是一本非常精彩的书。是的。他在书中谈到人们在这些沼泽岛屿上建立此类定居点。其中有一个特别典型的例子，对吧？他们在那里建立了一座神庙。
And he points to that as a sort of key moment in the emergence of this kind of proto urban culture, if you like. So tell us a bit about that, Tom. I'll actually quote Ben Wilson. I've got a lifted a passage from his wonderful book Metropolis on this. This is a shrine that's built around 5,400 BC. And Wilson says of it, on a sandbank beside a lagoon where the desert met the Mesopotamian marshes, perhaps at first people saw this place as sacred because
他将此视为这种原初城市文化兴起过程中的一个关键时刻。所以给我们讲讲这个，汤姆。我实际上要引用本·威尔逊的话。我摘录了他那本精彩的《大都会》中的一段话。这是一座建于公元前 5400 年左右的神庙。威尔逊这样描述它：在沙漠与美索不达米亚沼泽交汇处的一处泻湖旁的沙洲上，人们起初可能认为这个地方是神圣的，因为
the lagoon was a life-giving force. The earliest signs of human life here in the sandy island that would be called Eridu were the bones of fish and wild animals as well as mussel shells, suggesting this holy spot was a place of ritual feasting. In time, a small shrine was built to worship the god of fresh water. And then the centuries pass and Eridu is built and rebuilt and rebuilt and it becomes larger and larger and larger. And it comes to be seen by the people who live around it as the holiest place in the
泻湖是生命的源泉。这个后来被称为埃利都（Eridu）的沙岛上最早的人类生活迹象是鱼骨、野生动物骨骼以及贻贝壳，这表明这个神圣的场所曾是一个进行仪式性宴饮的地方。随着时间的推移，这里建立了一座小神庙来供奉淡水之神。接着，几个世纪过去了，埃利都经历了一次又一次的重建，规模变得越来越大。它被周围居住的人们视为了世界上最神圣的地方，
world, the place where the world itself emerged into being. Dry land is fashioned out of the primordial waters, kind of shaped and molded out of mud by the great god Enki. And the temple of Eridu is raised to Enki, and it serves as a symbol not just of the victory of order over chaos, of eternity over oblivion, but as the very place where the great god Enki, the creator God himself, actually lives. So if the God who ensures that order is preserved, that the lands around the sea don't just melt back into the chaos of the waters, you need to keep him on board. You need to keep him happy. And so inevitably, this results
也就是世界本身诞生的地方。干地从原始水域中被塑造出来，由伟大的神恩基（Enki）用泥土塑形捏造。埃利都的神庙被奉献给恩基，它不仅象征着秩序对混乱的战胜、永恒对遗忘的征服，而且还是伟大的神恩基——创造神本人——实际居住的地方。所以，如果你想确保秩序得以维持，确保海边周围的土地不会重新融化进水域的混乱之中，你就需要让这位神明站在你这边。你需要让他保持高兴。因此，这不可避免地导致了
in the emergence of a kind of priesthood. And they have authority over the people who are contributing labor and goods to this temple. Because they can say, well, if you don't do what we say, then the world will collapse and melt away. What it reminds me of is Stonehenge, which is built much later, but a similar process of a site that is clearly very holy, not just to locals, but to people from far across Britain. And you get people coming for great feasts at the site of Stonehenge. The temple itself remains kind of sacrosanct, but you do get signs of large villages, large settlements. But again, the comparison with Stonehenge only focuses the puzzle. How do you get from this temple on an island in southern Mesopotamia to the emergence of the first city, to the emergence of Uruk? Right, because Eridu
某种祭司阶层的兴起。他们对向这座神庙贡献劳动力和物资的人们拥有权威。因为他们可以说，如果你们不按我们说的做，世界就会崩溃并消融。这让我想起了巨石阵（Stonehenge），它建造的时间要晚得多，但有着相似的过程：一个显然非常神圣的遗址，不仅对当地人神圣，对远在英国各地的远方来客也同样神圣。你会看到人们来到巨石阵遗址举行盛大的宴会。神庙本身依然神圣不可侵犯，但你确实看到了大型村庄和大型定居点的迹象。不过，与巨石阵的类比只会让谜团更加集中。你究竟是如何从美索不达米亚南部一个岛屿上的这座神庙，过渡到第一座城市的兴起、过渡到乌鲁克的出现的呢？没错，因为埃利都
doesn't become a city, but Uruk does. There's some story, isn't there? Is there some sort of folk tale about how they get the idea from Eridu and they take it to Uruk? Have I remembered that right, Tom? Yes. So Enki is in his temple and basically he's being selfish. He's not sharing the gifts of civilization, the fruits of his knowledge. In Greek myth, he's a bit like Zeus hoarding fire. And in the Greek myth Prometheus, the Titan comes and steals fire and gives it to humanity and then human civilization can begin. And that role in Mesopotamian myth is played by the goddess we've already mentioned, Inanna,
并没有变成一座城市，但乌鲁克却成了。这里有一个传说，对吧？是不是有什么民间传说讲述他们是如何从埃利都获得这个想法并将其带到乌鲁克的？我没记错吧，汤姆？是的。恩基待在自己的神庙里，基本上他很自私。他没有分享文明的礼物、他知识的果实。在希腊神话中，他有点像囤积火种的宙斯。而在希腊神话中，泰坦神普罗米修斯（Prometheus）前来偷走火种并将其交给了人类，随后人类文明才得以开启。在美索不达米亚神话中，扮演这一角色的是我们已经提到过的女神伊南娜（Inanna），
who will become Ishtar to the Babylonians. And she steals the secrets of civilization from Enki by getting him drunk on beer. So she gets him pissed and she steals everything that he knows. I mean, if you like, it's a kind of data theft. Right. She moves in and she recognizes knowledge is power and she takes these secrets and she takes it to the Ayyana, the house of heaven that we mentioned as being this great temple in Uruk. And this is the place where she settles and it establishes a second focal point for the peoples of Southern Mesopotamia. Only this is the place where she settles and it establishes a second focal point for the peoples of southern Mesopotamia. Only this is one in which the God is not kind of hugging
她后来成了巴比伦人的伊什塔尔。她通过把恩基灌醉，从他那里偷走了文明的秘密。她把他灌得酩酊大醉，然后偷走了他所知道的一切。如果你愿意的话，这就像是一种数据盗窃。没错。她搬了过去，意识到知识就是力量，她偷走了这些秘密，并把它们带到了埃安纳（Ayyana）——我们之前提到过的乌鲁克那座宏伟神庙——也就是天堂之家。这里就是她定居的地方，并为美索不达米亚南部的人们建立了一个第二个焦点。只不过，在这里，神明并没有将
knowledge to himself but is generous with it, wants to share it with the whole of humanity. How does that story match the archaeological evidence of the temples in Uruk, Tom. Beautifully. I mean, this is why it's so wonderful. So I mentioned these two great temples that get founded about 5000 BC, Deyana and the neighboring temple, the temple to Anu, the sky god, the Kullaba. And they are like the temple to Enki on Eridu, that they are constantly being built and rebuilt and rebuilt. And each time they are rebuilt, the existing structure is kind of incorporated within it. So Gwendolyn Lyke in her book says the past and the memory are sealed in a new foundation laid quite literally upon the leveled remains. And the result as the centuries and then the millennia pass is architecture on an absolutely unprecedentedly monumental scale.
知识据为己有，而是慷慨大方，希望将其与全人类分享。这个故事与乌鲁克的考古证据如何吻合呢，汤姆？非常完美。我的意思是，这就是为什么它如此美妙。所以我提到这两座伟大的神庙大约在公元前 5000 年建立，即埃安纳和相邻的天空神安努的神庙——库拉巴（Kullaba）。它们就像埃利都的恩基神庙一样，不断地被建造、重建、再重建。每一次重建时，现有的结构都会被包容其中。因此，格温多琳·莱克在她的书中说，过去和记忆被封存在一个新的地基中，这个地基字面意义上就铺在被铲平的遗迹之上。其结果是，随着世纪和千年的流逝，建筑规模达到了空前绝后的宏大尺度。
These are by miles the largest structures that any humans have built at that time. And an obvious question, how are they building this and who's doing it? I mean, are they doing it with a willing workforce? Are they doing it with slaves? How's that happening? Well, the thing that's fascinating is that it does seem to be more voluntary than perhaps the kind of more pessimistic takes on the emergence of urbanism would have it. So there's a brilliant scholar of this whole process called Pieter Steinkeller.
与当时人类建造的任何其他结构相比，这些神庙在规模上要大出数倍。一个显而易见的问题是：他们是如何建造这些的？又是谁在建造？我的意思是，他们是用自愿的劳动力来建造的吗？他们是用奴隶吗？这是怎么回事？嗯，最迷人的是，与对城市化兴起的更悲观看法相比，这似乎确实更具自愿性。有一位研究这一整个过程的杰出学者叫彼得·斯坦凯勒（Pieter Steinkeller）。
He describes these kind of these cylinder seals, which are kind of tubes and you roll them in clay, they give you a kind of strip cartoon. So they're not exactly writing, but they are images encoded with meaning. And he refers to an assembly of cylinder seals and he describes them as being the only evidence of a potentially historical nature that survives from late prehistoric times. So that's amazing. I mean, before the invention of writing, there are pictorial representations that you can extrapolate information about what the people who lived in that period were doing. And what these seals suggest is that the construction of these great temples at what will become Uruk is a collective activity.
他描述了这些圆柱印章，它们类似于某种管状物，当你把它们在黏土上滚动时，就会呈现出类似连环画的带状图案。所以它们不完全是文字，但它们是编码了意义的图像。他提到了圆柱印章的组合，并将其描述为晚期史前时期幸存下来的、具有潜在历史性质的唯一证据。这太令人惊叹了。在文字发明之前，就已经有了可以推断出那一时期人们生活状况信息的图画表象。而这些印章表明，将成为乌鲁克的那些伟大神庙的建造是一项集体活动。
It records gifts of commodities and in fact, labor as well to Inanna, the deity of Uruk, and this implies a kind of, I guess a confederacy. Because people are giving the gifts. Yeah, from different settlements. Yeah, there must be some wider federation or something. But what this also implies is that it's not just Inanna who is the beneficiary of this, but Uruk itself. So to quote Steinkeller, it now becomes clear that Uruk, rather than being merely one of the participating settlements, was the focus and beneficiary of the system. So I absolutely love this because it turns
它记录了对乌鲁克神明伊南娜的物资甚至劳动力的捐赠，这暗示了一种某种意义上的联盟。因为人们在奉献礼物。是的，来自不同的定居点。是的，一定存在某种更广泛的联邦或其他组织。但这也意味着，受益者不仅是伊南娜，乌鲁克本身也是受益者。借用斯坦凯勒的话说，现在显而易见的是，乌鲁克并非仅仅是参与的定居点之一，而是这个系统的核心和受益者。我非常喜欢这一点，因为多米尼克，事实证明城市化的起源在于神圣的维度。我想是的。或者你也可以说这是一种殖民主义的形式，一个城市在从其邻近地区掠夺资源，难道不是吗？是的，但这是一种对神明的虔诚表现。而神圣性仅仅是历史核心——即权力的借口。
out that the origins of urbanism, Dominic, lies in the dimension of the sacral. I guess so. Or you could say a form of colonialism that one city is extracting resources from its neighbors. Could you not? Yes, but this is a display of devotion to the gods. And the sacrality is merely a pretext for what's at the heart of history, which is power. Well, you could say that the sacral and the manifestations of power in the here and now are so inter-fused that it becomes almost impossible to distinguish them. But just before we get to the break, Tom, they're not just building big temples and
好吧，你也可以说神圣性与此时此地的权力表现是如此交织融合，以至于几乎无法将它们区分开来。不过，在进入中场休息之前，汤姆，他们不只是在建造巨大的神庙
stuff like that, are they? No, they're not. They're also doing kind of engineering, sort of reshaping the landscape around them, I guess. Well, into the fourth millennium, the landscape is being reshaped by the climate because the sea is starting to retreat again. So it's gone right the way up into Iraq and now in the fourth millennium, it is starting to retreat back to where the Persian Gulf begins now.
之类的东西，对吧？不，他们没有。他们还在进行某种工程建设，比如重塑周围的景观。好吧，进入公元前四千年，由于海水开始退去，地貌正被气候重新塑造。所以它曾经一直延伸到伊拉克北部，而现在在公元前四千年，它开始退回到波斯湾如今的起点。
And as a consequence of this, the marshes are drying up. And so people who had been dependent for their food on the wildfowl in the marshes or the fish and the mollusks in the sea, are now having to look for other ways to sustain themselves. And so what they do, you know, it's obviously a terrible crisis for them, but they have these two great temples, which by now are millennia old, and they serve as reassurances, symbols that the gods will look after them, that they will uphold the order that emerged back in the beginning with Enki. So they flock to Uruk because it seems the safest place
由于海水的退去，沼泽正在干涸。因此，那些依赖沼泽中的水禽或海里的鱼类和软体动物来维持生计的人们，现在不得不寻找其他方式来养活自己。所以他们所做的（这显然对他们来说是一场巨大的危机）是依靠那两座历经千年的伟大神庙，它们成为了让他们安心的象征，证明神明会照顾他们，会维护当初由恩基开启的秩序。因此，他们蜂拥至乌鲁克，因为那里似乎是
to go. It's a kind of refuge. And the people who are coming are people who are very, very familiar with irrigation, with using water to sustain themselves and probably have the engineering skills that will enable Uruk to be sustained by building canals, by starting to fertilize the fields with water and so on. And Al-Ghazé in his book, fascinatingly compares this process to how Chicago emerged in the 19th century. He says that Chicago initially lived in what he describes as its natural landscape. So in other words, Chicago is built on, you know, as a great lakes port. That's what initially enables it to become a major settlement. But then in the 19th century, developments like expansion of the railroads, the opening up of the Wild West, refrigeration, enable it to serve as
最安全的去处。这是一种避难所。到来的人们对灌溉、用水维持生计非常熟悉，并且可能拥有能够使乌鲁克通过修建运河、开始用水灌溉农田等方式得以维系的工程技能。阿尔加泽在他的书中引人入胜地将这个过程与 19世纪芝加哥的崛起进行了对比。他说，芝加哥最初生活在他所描述的自然景观中。换句话说，芝加哥是作为一个五大湖港口建立起来的。这最初使它成为一个主要的定居点。但到了 19 世纪，诸如铁路扩张、美国西部大开发、制冷技术等发展，使它能够成为阿尔加泽所谓的由人工创造的景观的核心。你可以看到乌鲁克与之相似的地方。最初它的存在是因为拥有众多的泻湖、海水等等，但当海水退去时，你必须创造一个新的基础设施、一个新的环境。而乌鲁克证明了自己不仅能够应对这一切，不仅能生存下来，而且还能繁荣发展。好吧，太棒了。所以在这里，我们拥有了人类历史上第一座城市演变的故事，对吧？人类的景观也随之改变。你在前半部分提到过，你想谈谈它如何改变了我们，乌鲁克这座第一城市如何改变了身为人类的意义。所以
a focus for what Aghazi calls a created landscape. You can see the parallel there with Uruk. Initially it's there because you have all these lagoons, you know, the sea and everything, but when it retreats, you have to create a new infrastructure, a new environment. And Uruk proves able to deal with that as well and not just to survive, but to flourish. Okay, brilliant. So here we have the first story in human history of a city evolving, right? And the human landscape kind of changing. You mentioned in the first half that you wanted to talk about how it changes us, how Uruk, the first city, changes what it means to be human. So
让我们在休息之后再来探讨这个话题。现在，汤姆，我们有一些令人难以置信的激动人心的消息要与听众分享，对吧？当然有，多米尼克。我们要宣布推出《历史的剩余》官方周边商品。是的，你现在可以拥有一段历史了。字面意义上的。我们有T恤、马克杯、手机壳、笔记本，种类繁多，正赶上圣诞节。难以置信的场面，汤姆，因为这些可不仅仅是普通的T恤和马克杯。汤姆，这些都是《历史的剩余》独家设计款。没错，多米尼克。我们的新周边绝对是送给任何历史迷的完美礼物，无论
let's do that after the break. Now, Tom, we have something unbelievably exciting to share with our listeners, don't we? Absolutely we do, Dominic. We are announcing the launch of the Rest Is History merchandise. Yes, you can now own a piece of history. Literally. We've got shirts, mugs, phone cases, notebooks, so much just in time for Christmas. Unbelievable scenes, Tom, because these aren't just any shirts and mugs. Tom, these are exclusive Rest is History designs. That's right Dominic. And our new merch truly is the perfect gift for any history fan whether
他们是节目的老朋友，还是——我们敢这么说吗——尚未成为节目朋友的人。是的，我的意思是这真是一个令人难以置信的绝妙点子，不是吗？确实如此。因为如果你是节目的忠实朋友，你可以买一件自豪地表明你立场的T恤。如果你还需要说服，那么你也可以买一件“还不是节目的朋友”版本的T恤。所以这简直是一份超越梦想的礼物，对吧？我们将在社交媒体上分享你们穿着《历史的剩余》周边的最爱照片。所以请在圣诞节早晨把这些照片发给我们。所以请记得前往 www.goalhanger.shop 获取你们的周边。就像一个第一次盖房子的年轻人，就像一个确立了女性地位的女孩
they're a friend of the show or dare we say someone who's not yet a friend of the show. Yeah I mean this is an unbelievably cunning wheeze isn't it? Really is. Because if you're a loyal friend of the show you can buy a t-shirt that proudly declares your allegiance. And if you still need convincing, then you can buy a not a friend of the show version as well. So truly it's beyond a dream gift, isn't it? And we'll be sharing on social media our favourite pictures of you in your restless history merch. So send these in over Christmas morning. So remember to head to to head to www.goalhanger.shop to get your merch. Like a young man building a house for the first time, like a girl establishing a woman's
他们是节目的朋友，或者我们敢说，是一个还不是节目的朋友的人。是的，我的意思是这是一个令人难以置信的狡猾计谋，对吧？确实如此。因为如果你是节目的忠实朋友，你可以买一件自豪地宣明你忠诚的T恤。如果你还在犹豫，那么你也可以买一件“不是节目的朋友”版本的T恤。所以这简直是超越梦想的礼物，对吧？我们将在社交媒体上分享你们穿着无休止历史周边最喜欢的照片。所以请在圣诞节早晨把这些发过来。所以请记住前往 www.goalhanger.shop 购买你们的周边。就像一个第一次建房子的年轻人，像一个确立女性地位的女孩
domain, Holy Inanna did not sleep as she ensured that the warehouses would be provisioned, that dwellings would be founded in the city, that its people would eat splendid food, that they would drink splendid beverages, that those who had bathed for holidays would rejoice in the courtyards, that the people would throng the places of celebration, that acquaintances would dine together, that foreigners would cruise about like unusual birds in the sky. Elephants, water buffalo, exotic animals, as well as thoroughbred dogs, lions, mountain ibexes, and sheep with long wool would jostle each other in the public squares. The city walls, like a mountain, reached the heavens." So that's from the Curse of Akkad, a poem that was written in about 2000 BC, so long after the heyday of Uruk. We're
领域，神圣的伊南娜没有入睡，她确保仓库里物资充足，城内建起居所，人们能吃到美酒佳肴，在庭院里为节日沐浴的人们欢欣鼓舞，人们涌向庆祝的场所，熟人共进晚餐，外国人在空中如奇鸟般四处游荡。大象、水牛、珍奇动物，以及纯种狗、狮子、高山野山羊和长毛绵羊在公共广场上摩肩接踵。城墙如大山般直插云霄。”这段话出自《阿卡德的诅咒》，这是一首写于公元前2000年左右的诗，远在乌鲁克全盛时期之后。我们
recording this in New York and our American listeners will be very pleased there by the mention of beverages, Tom, or what in English we call drinks. So tell us about Akkad. So Akkad is often seen as one of the great early cities, isn't it? So Akkad is the capital of Sargon. Yeah, so it's a purpose-built capital. Sargon is the first great imperial conqueror, and that poem describes the fall not of Uruk, but of Akkad around 2000 BC. So that's 3000 years after the founding of Uruk. And the reason that that poem describes Inanna as the foundress of Akkad is that Sargon and his heirs had attempted to appropriate everything that Uruk was and kind of attribute it to this new upstart city of Akkad. So he describes Sargon in one inscription describes himself as the overseer of Inanna,
在纽约录制这期节目，我们的美国听众听到刚才提到的饮料一定会非常高兴，汤姆，或者我们在英语中称之为 drinks。那么给我们讲讲阿卡德吧。阿卡德通常被视为早期伟大的城市之一，对吧？阿卡德是萨尔贡的首都。是的，它是一座专门建造的首都。萨尔贡是第一位伟大的帝国征服者，那首诗描述的不是乌鲁克的灭亡，而是公元前2000年左右阿卡德的灭亡。这比乌鲁克的建立晚了3000年。那首诗将伊南娜描述为阿卡德的奠基者，原因在于萨尔贡及其继承者曾试图将乌鲁克的一切据为己有，并将其归功于阿卡德这座新崛起的新兴城市。因此，萨尔贡在一处铭文中将自己描述为伊南娜的监督者，
another as the anointed one of Anu, It's an illustration of the way in which the path that is blazed by Uruk is followed by countless cities, countless conquerors, countless great leaders in the millennia that follow it. And I guess there would be a parallel with, you know, the barbarians who conquer the Roman Empire or China. Once they have subdued the empires, they want a bit of it. This is why they've come. They want the wealth, they want the sophistication, they want the character and the color and
另一处则将自己描述为安努的受膏者。这说明了乌鲁克开辟的道路在随后的几千年里被无数城市、无数征服者和无数伟大领袖所遵循的方式。我想这可以与征服罗马帝国或中国的蛮族进行类比。一旦他们征服了这些帝国，他们就想分一杯羹。这就是他们来的原因。他们想要财富，想要精致的文化，想要这些伟大社会的性格、色彩
the mythology of these great societies. But there is a difference because the debt that the cities of Mesopotamia like Akkad owe to Uruk is infinitely profound. I mean, Uruk is the prototype, not just of a civilization like Rome or China, but of civilization itself. There has been nothing like it ever. You've compared it in your notes to AI. So an absolute game changer. So something that changes the human condition, what it is to be human and to live in the world, exciting, but also potentially dangerous, indeed deadly.
和神话。但还是有区别的，因为美索不达米亚城市（如阿卡德）对乌鲁克的债务是极其深重的。我的意思是，乌鲁克不仅是罗马或中国这样的文明的雏形，而且是文明本身的雏形。过去从未有过这样的东西。你在笔记中将它比作人工智能。所以这是一个绝对的规则改变者。也就是说，它改变了人类的状况、身为人类和在世间生存的意义，既令人兴奋，但也具有潜在的危险，甚至是致命的。
Yeah. The other parallel with AI is that the real transformation is in the world. Exciting, but also potentially dangerous, indeed deadly. Yeah. The other parallel with AI is that the real transformation is in the dimension less of hardware than of software. So in the rewiring of the brain itself. And in fact, you could say that the city is kind of like an enormous brain, a collective brain. And the existence of this brain kind of requires new ways of thinking, but it also generates new ways of thinking. And these new ways of thinking in turn result in new forms of social organization, of communication, and maybe just, you know, of conceptualizing the very nature of what it is to be human and how humanity relates to the broader cosmos, the broader universe. So you've given an example in your notes haven't you, of two innovations that come about because of the need to cope with particular challenges. And those are challenges really at born of
是的。与人工智能的另一个相似之处在于，真正的转变更多地发生在软件维度，而不是硬件维度。也就是说，它重塑了人类的大脑本身。事实上，你可以说城市就像一个巨大的大脑，一个集体大脑。这个大脑的存在既需要新的思维方式，也会产生新的思维方式。而这些新的思维方式反过来又会产生新的社会组织形式、交流形式，也许还有（你知道的）对人类本质以及人类如何与更广泛的宇宙相联系的全新概念化理解。所以你在笔记中举了一个例子，关于因应特定挑战而产生的两项创新。这些挑战实际上源于
scale because a city like Uruk, it needs stuff, it needs supplies, it needs materials, it needs food. So talk us through these two innovations. So these are on the technical level, the technological level. Yeah. So this is hardware rather than software. And one of these is the domestication of the humble donkey, which the people of Uruk seem to have been the first to domesticate. And the stats on this are striking.
规模，因为像乌鲁克这样的城市，它需要东西，需要补给，需要材料，需要食物。给我们讲讲这两项创新吧。这些是在技术层面上的。是的。这是硬件，而不是软件。其中之一就是驯服谦逊的驴，乌鲁克人似乎是第一批驯服驴的人。这方面的数据非常惊人。
So it's been estimated that a train of say 40 donkeys could carry almost 7,000 pounds of cargo over 20 miles a day. And again, if you think of the parallel with Chicago, the invention of the railroads opens up vast, vast stretches of territory that the people of Chicago can now exploit and in its own humble way, the donkey is kind of doing the same. And the other thing that seems to have been developed in Uruk is the wheel and the axle. And again, that's responding to a need, but it's also because you have people
据估计，一支由大约40头驴组成的驴队可以在一天内将近7000磅的货物运送20多英里。同样，如果你想想与芝加哥的类比，铁路的发明开辟了广袤的领土，芝加哥人现在可以利用这些领土，而以它自己的方式，驴也在做着同样的事情。乌鲁克开发的另一项东西是轮子和车轴。同样，这也是对需求的响应，但这也是因为你拥有
who would be qualified to come up with this kind of invention. You have very skilled craftsmen who can shape wheels, who can shape axles and so on. So again, it's not surprising that it's in Uruk that this kind of momentous innovation emerges. Because you need tools to make these things. So that spurs an innovation of a different kind. Because we're in Mesopotamia, it's also in the Tigris and the Euphrates.
能够想出这种发明的人才。你拥有技艺高超的工匠，他们可以制作车轮、车轴等等。因此，这种重大的创新出现在乌鲁克也就不足为奇了。因为你需要工具来制造这些东西。这就刺激了另一种创新。因为我们在美索不达米亚，它也在底格里斯河和幼发拉底河畔。
So sails, right? Boats. They are bringing stuff in by water as well. So that must be a massively important thing. And I guess that gives you a sense of the idea that the city is the hub of a great network that extends out beyond itself, that it's not self-sufficient, that they're bringing stuff in, you know, metals or food or whatever.
所以有帆，对吧？船只。他们也通过水路运送物资。这一定是一件极其重要的事情。我想这让你有这样一种感觉：城市是一个庞大网络的核心，这个网络向外延伸，它不是自给自足的，他们必须输入物资，无论是金属、食物还是其他东西。
Or wood particularly, because there's almost no wood in Mesopotamia. Yeah. Now here's a question for you. So in the first half I said, you know, is it like a colonial relationship kind of exploiting the hinterland? So is it? Are they paying for this stuff or are they just taking it? Well, this is much debated. There are scholars, though, Al-Ghazze, he's very keen on the idea that there is a kind
或者特别是木材，因为美索不达米亚几乎没有木材。是的。现在我有个问题要问你。在前半部分，我说过，这是否有点像剥削腹地的殖民关系？是这样的吗？他们是为这些东西付费，还是直接拿走？嗯，这争论很大。不过，有学者如阿尔-加泽（Al-Ghazze），他非常倾向于这样一种观点：这里建立了一种类似殖民系统的东西。还有其他人说这在很大程度上是一个贸易网络。但话说回来，这让我想到了关于英国作为第一个工业化国家的角色的辩论。工业化进程是建立殖民系统的原因吗？还是反过来的？还是兼而有之？很显然，正如对英国一样，对乌鲁克来说，作为品牌引领者，作为第一个
of colonial system that gets established. There are others who say it's largely a trading network. But again, I mean, this reminds me of debates around Britain's role as the first industrial nation. Is the process of industrialization what enables the colonial system to be established? Is it the other way around? Is it a bit of both? And it's clear that as with Britain, so with Uruk, being the brand leader, the first to
以最大化产出的方式组织社会的人，极大地开辟了贸易联系，因为你可以控制这些贸易联系，然后你就有东西可以卖了。因此，乌鲁克同时也在发生的事情是，陶器、纺织品、金属等东西正以空前规模和高度精致度被开发出来，这在历史上是前所未见的。因此，乌鲁克的陶工似乎发明了陶轮和窑炉，使得越来越多的陶器得以生产出来。
develop a way of organizing your society in a way that maximizes what you can produce, it massively opens up trade links because you can control those trade links and you then have things to sell. So what is also happening in Uruk is that things like pottery, things like textiles, things like metals are being developed on a scale and with a degree of sophistication that again has never been seen ever in history. So potters in Uruk seem to have developed the potter's wheel, kilns that enable more and more pots to be developed.
一种非常非常独特的陶器在乌鲁克制造出来，并且在叙利亚、安纳托利亚甚至远至现在的巴基斯坦等地都被发现。当然，这也鼓励了外国社群模仿乌鲁克。一个伟大的出口强国能够塑造那些进口国的人的品味。从这个意义上说，这是一种文化殖民主义，对吧？因此，这必然是一种我们前所未见的规模的生产。
Very, very distinctive kind of pottery is made in Uruk and it's been found across, you know, in Syria, in Anatolia, even as far as what's now Pakistan. And of course this encourages foreign communities to model themselves on Uruk. You know, a great exporting power is able to shape the tastes of those who are importing them. And in that sense, there's a kind of cultural colonialism, isn't there? This must therefore be kind of production on a kind of scale that we haven't seen before.
所以无论是纺织品、陶器还是其他什么的生产。这再次强化了与英国工业革命的类比。英国发展了大规模生产，你知道，它拥有18世纪末和19世纪初的原型工厂。如果乌鲁克能做到这一点，那就意味着它拥有人类历史上任何社群从未达到过的组织水平。是这样吗？是的。你知道的，我曾说过，乌鲁克的力量最生动地体现在软件维度而非硬件维度。这一领域有两个真正的创新。
So production of the textiles or the pottery or whatever. And again, that reinforces that kind of parallel with Britain in the industrial revolution. The Britain has developed mass production, you know, it's got the prototypical factories of the late 18th and early 19th century. And if Uruk can do this, then that must mean it has a level of organization that no community in human history has ever had to this point. Would that be right? Yeah. You know, I said how it's really in the dimension of software rather than hardware that Uruk's potency is most vividly displayed. And there are two real kind of innovations in that field.
首先是现在我们所说的数据管理领域。没错。乌鲁克，特别是乌鲁克市中心的伊南娜大神庙，是世界上任何地方发现的最早保存下来的文字的发源地。如果我们不把我们在塞尔维亚讨论过的那些文字算作真正的文字的话。这基本上就是文字发明的地方，我们可以详细追踪它的演变。我所描述的那种圆柱印章，那种你可以在上面刻上细节、图画等圆形管子，然后
So the first is in the field of what we would now call data management. Right. And Uruk and specifically the great temple to Inanna in the heart of Uruk is home to the earliest surviving writing found anywhere in the world. If we discount that writing that we talked about in Serbia as not actually being writing. This essentially is where writing is invented and we can trace its evolution in some detail. So those cylinder seals that I described, those kind of circular tubes that you inscribe details on drawings and so on, and you then
在泥土上滚动它们。这些印章上刻有各种图案，这些图案开始向象形图转变，也就是传达大量信息的图像，能够被相当广泛的官僚群体所理解。然后你会有被称为“泥球”（bullae）的东西——小球，小的空心泥球。这些泥球里面装着小的泥制筹码。这些筹码有点像大富翁棋盘上的物件之类的东西，是的，就像棋盘游戏筹码一样。它们的形状代表了某种你想要出售的商品。
roll them in clay. These are illustrated with kind of motifs that are starting to move towards kind of pictograms, so images that are conveying quite a lot of information that will be understood by quite a broad array of of bureaucrats and then you have things that are called bull eye so little balls little hollow clay balls and these contain little clay tokens and these tokens a bit like I suppose items on a monopoly board or something yeah like board game tokens yeah they are shaped to represent a kind of you know something that you want to sell a commodity. So I don't know, a roll of cloth or a pot or a jar of oil or something
比如，一块布、一个陶罐、一罐油或类似的东西。这些基本上就是合同。所以你们有一个协议，如果这是一笔交付陶器的交易，你有一个罐子，你把它放进这个泥球里，然后你把它带到神庙，把它留在那里，一旦合同完成，你就可以砸开泥球，取出记账筹码，这证明合同已经履行，协议可以合法终止。随着时间的推移，这些各种各样的图像开始演变成我们所认识的文字。所以它们演变成，众所周知的楔形图像。因此根据拉丁语，这被称为楔形文字。
like that. And these are basically contracts. So you have an agreement, you know, if it's to deliver a load of pottery, you have a pot, you put it in this bull eye in this kind of clay ball, and then you take it to the temple, you leave it there and then once the contract has been completed, you crack open the clay ball and the accounting tokens are removed and this demonstrates that the contract has been fulfilled and the agreement can be legally terminated. Over the course of time, these various images start to evolve to become what we would recognize as writing. So they kind of evolve into, well, famously kind of wedge shaped images. So from the Latin, this comes to be called cuneiform.
这将成为一种持续数千年的文字形式。作为一个文学和诗歌爱好者，我总是感到清醒的一点是，你意识到识字和写作的起点不是诗人。正如我一直想象的那样，它不是始于讲故事的人，而是始于会计。噢，汤姆，我太喜欢这个了。
And this will be a form of writing that will endure for thousands and thousands of years. And the thing that I was as an enthusiast for literature and poetry. Yeah. The thing I always find sobering about this is you realise that literacy and writing begins not with poets. It begins not with storytellers, as I'd always imagined, but with accountants. Oh, Tom, I love this.
神奇的是，我们可能还保留了其中一位会计的名字。大约在公元前四千年晚期，一个书吏写了一张收据。到这个时候，你知道的，文字已经发展到你可以把它写下来的程度。这个书吏写下了28,086大麦，37个月，库辛（Kushim）。那么库辛是什么或谁呢？库辛可能是某个职位或特定机构的持有人的名字，但它更有可能是一个个人。
And amazingly, we probably have the name of one of these accountants. So sometime in the late fourth millennium, a scribe writes a receipt. By this point, you know, the writing has developed that you can put it into writing. And this scribe wrote down 28,086 barley, 37 months, kushim. So what or who is kushim? So kushim could be the name of, you know, the holder of an office or a particular institution, but it's much more likely that it is an individual.
引用本·威尔逊（Ben Wilson）的话，如果是这样，库辛就是历史上面我们所知的第一个人。天哪。而他是个会计。所以任何听到这个的会计师们，（你知道的）给自己拍拍肩膀吧。为了让大家感受到“躁动历史俱乐部”（Restless History Club）是多么令人兴奋和充满乐趣，我们的俱乐部里有很多会计师。税务专家等等。
And so to quote Ben Wilson, if so, Kushim is the very first person in history whose name we know. Crikey. And he's an accountant. So any accountants out there listening to this, you know, pat yourselves on the back. To give people a sense of just how exciting and fun packed the Restless History Club is, we have a lot of accountants in the Restless History Club. Tax specialists and whatnot.
我希望他们会喜欢这个。他们一定会喜欢这一切。他们对此了如指掌。是的。但现在我们要换一个稍微黑暗一点的视角来看待会计师在城市化兴起中所扮演的角色，因为我说过有这两个创新。另一个是只能被真正描述为对劳动力的大规模剥削。
I hope they will enjoy that. They'd love all this. They're all over this. Yeah. But now a slightly darker perspective on the role played by accountants in the emergence of urbanization, because I said that there are these two innovations. The other one is what you can only really describe as the mass exploitation of labour.
所以我们讨论的唯一词汇就是奴隶制。嗯，这有待讨论，是的，到这个时候绝对已经有了奴隶制。我们从另一张收据中得知这一点，这张收据可能写于库辛写下第一张收据几代人之后。它写在一块泥板上，是一份所有权记录。主人是一个叫加尔·萨尔（Gal Sal）的男人。疯狂的名字，疯狂的家伙。嗯，但他的男奴的名字甚至更疯狂。叫 N-PAP-X。我的意思是，他有点像个说唱歌手，对吧？
So we're talking the only word slavery. Well to be discussed, yes, there is definitely slavery by this point. And we know this from another receipt that's written maybe a couple of generations after Cushim wrote that very first receipt. And it's on a tablet and it's a record of ownership. And the owner is a man called Gal Sal. Crazy name, crazy guy. Well, but the name of his male slave is even crazier. It's N-PAP-X. I mean, he's kind of like a rapper, isn't it?
这简直就像是来自未来的东西。N-PAP-X。还有一个女奴叫苏克·阿尔吉娅（Sukh Algea）。这是第二批（你知道的）历史上被点名的人。其中有两个是奴隶。这表明了文字、城市主义和文明从一开始就与奴隶制共存。我说它不仅是奴隶制，而且比那更广泛的原因在于，它是关于对更广泛意义上的所谓工人阶级的剥削。它本质上反映了这样一个事实：似乎不可能拥有一种像城市那样复杂和庞大的生活系统，而没有被富人剥削去做脏活累活的人。
It's just something from the future. N-PAP-X. And there's a female slave called Sukh Algea. And this is the second, you know, these are the second group of people named in history. And two of them are slaves. And it demonstrates how writing and urbanism and civilization coexists with slavery right from the beginning. And the reason that I said it's not just slavery, it's much broader than that. It's about the exploitation of what you might call the working classes more generally. And it reflects the fact, essentially it seems impossible to have a system of living as complex and vast as a city without having people who are exploited by the rich to do the dirty jobs.
他们可能是奴隶，可能是特定种姓的人，可能是农奴，可能是受压迫的劳工，但从一开始，他们就在那里。阿尔-加泽对此做了精彩而极其阴暗的总结。所以他写道，古代近东村民驯化了动植物。而乌鲁克城市机构反过来驯化了人类。那么，这些人会是被战争俘虏的人吗？是的，也许吧。例如，你知道阿兹特克帝国的特诺奇蒂特兰人，这些人会是在大范围袭击中俘获的人，或者在某种我不知道的仪式性战役中俘获的人，然后被带回来在土地上劳作、做所有的脏活累活吗，你觉得呢？
And they might be slaves, they might be, you know, people from a particular caste, they might be serfs, they might be oppressed laborers, but right from the beginning, they are there. And Al-Ghazai sums this up brilliantly and very sinisterly. So he writes, early Near Eastern villagers, domesticated plants and animals. Uruk's urban institutions in turn domesticated humans. So would these be people seized in wars? Yeah maybe. For example you know that the people in Tenochtitlan in the Aztec Empire, would these be people captured in great raids or in kind of I don't know ritualistic campaigns or something and then brought back to work on the land and to work in doing all the dirty jobs, do you think?
到公元前四千年末，乌鲁克印章上的图案绝对开始出现被拴住的囚犯、双手被绑、由武装士兵和武装战士看守的形象。但也有本地出生的奴隶。同样，引用阿尔-加泽的话，你会有外国和本土出生的俘虏被用作劳工，官僚和会计用年龄和性别类别来描述他们，这些类别与用来描述国家拥有的畜群的类别完全相同，包括各种类型的牛和猪。所以你把人类当作商品，你知道的，与牲畜处于同一水平。事实上，不仅是牲畜，还有更广泛意义上的商品。
Definitely by the end of the fourth millennium, you were starting to get images on seals in Uruk that do show kind of prisoners tethered, their hands bound up, guarded by armed soldiers, by armed warriors. But there are also native-born slaves as well. And again, to quote Al-Ghazai, you get foreign and native-born captives used as laborers, and they are described by the bureaucrats, by the accountants, with age and sex categories identical to those used to describe state-owned herded animals, including various types of cattle and pigs. So you're getting humans as commodities, you know, that are on a level with livestock. And in fact, not just livestock, but commodities
所以在我们拥有的所有来自乌鲁克的各种文本中，大麦是被提及最多的商品，有496次。但排在它后面的商品是女奴。真的吗？对她们的提及有388次。这是一个相当严峻的故事，对吧？你可能会好奇为什么特别是女奴。我认为答案在于纺织业的重要性，这再次与英国的工业革命形成了对比，纺织业在欧洲规模巨大。
more generally. So in all the various texts that we have from Uruk, Bali is the commodity that gets the most mentions, 496. But the commodity that comes after that is female slaves. Really? And you get 388 mentions of them. That's a pretty grim story, isn't it? And you might wonder why particularly female slaves. And I think the answer to that is the importance of the textile industry, which again is such a comparison with the industrial
所以他们不再真正使用亚麻了。到现在为止，他们使用的是从绵羊身上取下的羊毛，他们需要女奴来做这件事。纺织品的制造在美索不达米亚被刻板地视为女性扮演的角色。如果你要大规模地进行生产，那么根据证据，乌鲁克人似乎觉得他们需要奴隶来完成这项工作。所以，是的，有点严峻。
revolution in Britain, that the textile industry is massive in Europe. So it's no longer really flax that they're using. They're using wool by now taken from the sheep and they need female slaves to do it. Weaving the manufacture of commodities is seen in Mesopotamia stereotypically as the role that is played by women. And if you're going to do it on a vast scale, then effectively, it seems from the evidence, the people of Uruk felt that they needed slaves to do it. So yeah, kind of grim.
因此，关于城市主义、城市和文明，从一开始就有这种黑暗而可怕的一面。所以，如果你像我一样是一个对人性持悲观态度的人，你对此就不会感到太惊异。因为我不是在写文章说印章上的画面展示了畏缩的囚犯和被卫兵包围的人之类的情景，某种程度上这也是意料之中的。这里存在一种对权力和统治以及压迫的庆祝。我的意思是，你还能用什么别的词呢？是的，但是随之发展出了一种更令人担忧的趋势，当然就是到这个时候（即公元前四千年末），当你开始获得向乌鲁克运送俘虏的证据时，你也会开始发现乌鲁克人不再是一个单一的城市了，竞争对手开始出现。
So right from the start about urbanism, the city, civilisation, has this kind of dark and terrifying side. So if you're a sort of pessimistic person about human nature as I am, you won't be very surprised by this. Because I'm not writing and saying the pictures on the seals, they show prisoners cowering and people surrounded by guards and stuff like that, which is in a way what you would expect. There is a sort of celebration of power and domination and oppression. I mean, that's what other words can you use? Yes, but the development of a further kind of worrying trend, which is of course that by this time, so the end of the fourth millennium, when you're starting to get the evidence of transportation of captives to Uruk, you are also starting to see that the people
假以时日，你知道的，阿卡德将成为其中之一。是的。因此，这些巨大的城墙建于公元前3000年左右。这似乎表明，到了这个时候，乌鲁克正受到来自竞争对手的威胁。乌鲁克在那之后又存活了700年，但当萨尔贡在公元前2300年左右出现时，他摧毁了城墙，将其夷为平地。到那时，伊南娜的大神庙埃安纳（Eanna）已经因为无人知晓的原因被夷为平地了。你知道的，为什么会这样？
of Uruk are no longer the single city anymore, that rivals are starting to grow. And in due course, you know, Akkad will be one of them. Yeah. So these great city walls are built around 3000 BC. And this seems to kind of indicate the fact that by this point Uruk is coming under threat from rivals. And Uruk survives, you know, another 700 years after that, but when Sargon turns up in around 2300, he destroys the walls, levels them to the ground, and by that point the Ayyana, the great temple to Inanna, had already been levelled for reasons that nobody knows. You know, why this had
这似乎是出于内部原因，但我们不知道为什么。随着萨尔贡的征服，乌鲁克基本上失去了它古老的荣耀和至高无上的地位，永远消失了。它仍然是一个重要的地方，但它作为第一座城市的地位的记忆被遗忘了。美索不达米亚人并没有把乌鲁克记为第一座城市，话虽如此，关于乌鲁克古老荣耀的记忆并非全部被遗忘。我给你们读一段写乌鲁克的诗句：一平方英里的城市，一平方英里的花园，一平方英里的泥坑，半平方英里的伊南娜居所，三平方英里半是乌鲁克的面积。
happened. It seemed to have been for internal reasons, but we don't know why. And with the conquest by Sargon, Uruk, basically, its ancient glory, its ancient supremacy is lost forever. It remains a significant place, but the memory of its status as having been the first city is forgotten. The Mesopotamians don't remember Uruk as being the very first city, but having said that, not everything about Uruk's ancient glory is forgotten. So I'll read you lines from a poem written about Uruk. One square mile of city, one square mile of gardens, one square mile of clay pits, a half square mile of Inanna's dwelling, three and a half square miles is the measure of Uruk.
这些诗句出自《吉尔伽美什》。哦，吉尔伽美什。我想知道吉尔伽美什会不会登场。是的。毫无疑问，他是美索不达米亚最著名的诗歌和伟大的史诗。我们有许多不同的版本，吉尔伽美什与乌鲁克的渊源可以追溯到两方面。首先，他似乎是一个真实的人。他似乎是一个生活在大约公元前2900年的国王。
And those are lines from Gilgamesh. Oh, Gilgamesh. I wondered if Gilgamesh might pitch up. Yeah. By miles, the most famous of Mesopotamian poems in a great work, great epic. We have it in many different versions and Gilgamesh doubly derives from Uruk. So first of all, he seems to have been a real person. He seems to have been a king who lived maybe around 2,900.
现在你开始有了大人物、大老板，被称为卢加尔（Lugal），被称为大人物，就像美索不达米亚的戴利市长（Mayor Daley）。是的。那就是吉尔伽美什。但吉尔伽美什不可能没有乌鲁克而被写出来的另一个原因，当然是它正在被书写这一事实，即文字已经被开发出来，因此曾经用于会计的东西现在被用来写诗等等。会计的工具已经变成了
And the fact that you are now having kind of big men, big bosses, the Lugal, they're called the big man, so like Mayor Daley of Mesopotamia. Yeah. Yeah. So that's who Gilgamesh was. But the other way in which Gilgamesh could not have been written without Uruk is of course the fact that it is being written, that writing has been developed and so what had been used for accountancy is now being used to write poetry and so on. The accountants tool has become
诗人的工具，汤姆。没错，所以这并非全是坏事。吉尔伽美什为美索不达米亚人（一直到巴比伦时代及以后）所做的另一件事是，它保留了乌鲁克与伊南娜的联系，因为诗中的吉尔伽美什经常被塑造为伊南娜的专用仆人。事实上，在诗的最早版本中，他前来拯救伊南娜的神圣树木，这棵树正受到一只阴险的鸟的威胁。这就是吉尔伽美什最初所做的事情。我们确实喜欢阴险的鸟。你知道的，我们讨论过城市主义的馈赠是如何黑暗的，它强加给人类一种新的生活方式，你可能会觉得也许我们继续当狩猎采集者或者别的什么会更好。我不这么认为。
the poet's tool Tom. Exactly, so it's not all bad. And the other thing that Gilgamesh does for the Mesopotamians into the age of Babylon and so on is that it preserves the association of Uruk with Inanna, because Gilgamesh in the poem is often cast as the particular servant of Inanna. And in fact, in the very earliest version of the poem, he comes to the rescue of Inanna's sacred tree, which is being menaced by a sinister bird. So that's what Gilgamesh does originally. We do like a sinister bird. You know, we've talked about how the gifts of urbanism are dark ones, that it imposes on humanity, a new way of living, which you might think maybe we'd have been better off carrying on as hunter gatherers or whatever. I don't think so.
但是伊南娜一直到（我不知道）波斯、希腊或罗马时代，都被人们铭记为快乐女神。所以她不仅是文明艺术的女神，也是让城市充满乐趣的一切事物的女神。因此，乌鲁克被誉为一个充满节日、歌声和舞蹈的地方。最后，我将引用格温多琳·莱克（Gwendolyn Leick）关于乌鲁克这一方面以及伊南娜在神话中所扮演的角色的这段话来结束。伊南娜，格温多琳·莱克论述乌鲁克的这一方面、伊南娜在神话中所扮演的角色。伊南娜，
But Inanna right the way up to, I don't know, the age of the Persians or the Greeks or the Romans is remembered as the goddess of pleasure. So she's not just the goddess of the arts of civilization, but of everything that makes a city fun. So Uruk is celebrated as a place of festivals, of singing and dancing. And I'll just finish by quoting from Gwendolyn Lyke on this aspect of Uruk, the role that Inanna plays in her mythology. Inanna, Gwendolyn Lyke on this aspect of Uruk, the role that Inanna plays in her mythology. Inanna, Gwendolyn Lyke writes, stands for the erotic potential of city life, which is set apart from the strict social control of the tribal community or the village. She frequents the taverns and ale houses where men could meet single women, and she is said to prowl the streets of Kulab in search of sexual adventure.
格温多琳·莱克写道，代表了城市生活的色情潜力，这与部落社区或村庄严格的社会控制截然不同。她经常光顾小酒馆和啤酒屋，男人可以在那里遇到单身女性，据说她还在库拉布（Kulab）的街道上徘徊，寻找性冒险。街头交媾显然是一件正常而快乐的事情，而在后期的诗歌中，年轻人独自睡在自己的房间里被特别指出是一种最令人担忧的状况。所以我想你可以这样评价乌鲁克：也许被人们记住的原因中还有比这更糟糕的。
Copulation in the streets was apparently a normal and joyful event and young people sleeping in their own chambers is singled out in a late poem as a most worrying state of affairs. And so I guess you could say of O'Rourke that maybe there are worse things to be remembered for. Brilliant, brilliant, Tom. So that was an absolute tour de force and we're in Manhattan and outside our windows of our hotel at this very moment, people may be performing in a similar way. Copulating in the streets. So I think we should head out and investigate Tom and on that bombshell
太棒了，太棒了，汤姆。这绝对是一次精彩绝伦的演讲，我们身在曼哈顿，就在此时此刻我们酒店窗外，人们可能正在以类似的方式表演。在街头交媾。所以我想我们应该出去调查一下，汤姆，带着这个重磅炸弹
we'll leave the rest of you to contemplate city life. Thank you very much and goodbye. Bye bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们将剩下的时间留给大家去思考城市生活。非常感谢，再见。拜拜。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。